I'm Cooper Kupp
and we're playing:
I'm gonna be given a category,
I gotta choose one to start, one to bench, and one to cut.
"Remember the Titans," start for sure,
I'm benching...
"Friday Night Lights," and I'm cutting, "Rudy," sorry.
I've got a lot of respect for "Rudy," but
those first two are my first two favorites, so I gotta go with it.
Super speed start,
I'm gonna go telepathy,
telepathy bench
and I'm...
cutting super strength.
For what I need to do day to day it just doesn't come into play.
It's not what I need.
I'm going,
I'mma go Tiger Woods start.
For Tiger to do what he did for so long
and have to come back through a lot of injuries, a lot of off-the-course stuff,
to be able to come back and do what he did at the Masters,
I think that takes a lot
and it's something that I don't think you've seen in sports ever,
that kind of a comeback.
Go with Tiger start,
Tom Brady,
bench,
Serena...
It's hard, it's really hard, I don't even know.
That's who I'm gonna go with.
I'm going wings start
seven-layer dip bench
and,
I'm cutting...
Pizza.
Did anyone not say wings?
I feel like wings has to be number one.
I'm either a honey barbecue or buffalo.
"SpongeBob" start,
I don't know what "Rick & Morty" is,
so I'm gonna have to cut that one.
And then I'mma go "South Park" on the bench.
Ooh, favorite "SpongeBob" episode?
I think when Krusty Krab starts selling pizzas.
I'm Cooper Kupp, and this was Start, Bench, Cut.